you ladies and gentlemen good evening uh
members of the public good evening
welcome to uh T District Council uh
internal um oversight and scrutiny
committee meeting
um first of all do we have any apologies
for absence have full house uh let us
move straight to the minutes of our last
meeting um and G page number as listed
online um please comment or put your
hand up if you have anything any comment
on uh the various Pages page
three page page
four page
five page
six page
seven uh can I have somebody who would
um propose those as a true record thank
you um councelor in and seconded by
Council
czy
[Music]
um and sorry yeah as always we have to
take um a vote on that having been um
proposed all those in favor
please anybody against those
abstentions one lovely thank
you um moving to
the um action list is on um
page
nine
um there as we can see um
the request for further information on
um the Energy Efficiency Etc the ice
machine at the fish do and the answer
there um where
um who posst that was that that you
James you in was it um you happy without
response fairly fairly full response and
actually it it it it looks like we're we
we've getting Valu for our effort
of certain I had was obviously when when
the fisherman's corpor finished we spent
an awful lot of money on ice machines on
pet on on diesel and the rest of it and
I just noticed this the last machine was
not very
effective yeah clearly obvious this new
one is is step in the right direction
yeah this is obviously going the right
way um the next item
um 268 um that we have I have a a a
meeting booked with the chief executive
um and Phil but in order to um we're
meeting next week I think AR we I Just
sh my diar it wasn't loading quick
enough I next week or week after it's
next week I think I just to show you no
it's not a complete BL in fact you're
right it's a week after we're meeting on
the
21st um to look at
the elements of um Environmental
Protection um that would be suitable to
include Within in the enforcement brief
that we want we've agreed that we want
to look at planning but we've also
agreed that the the full breath of
Environmental Protection was a
bottomless pit in a way and we were
going to just
um concentrate on on the key areas and
I'm meeting in a couple of weeks time to
sort that so that is in um in
hand um you'll also note that the uh we
lost an item off the agenda for tonight
um we were going to have uh presentation
on the asset management side the I
reluctantly had to agree um officers are
not in a position yet to
um present that fully to us and there is
no point in us taking it if the um
material wasn't complete so I have
agreed that it would would be delayed
and when we come to the uh forward plan
we'll see that but um uh unfortunately
that dropped from the
agenda um
okay do we have any public contributions
yes sir thank you very much um
Declarations of Interest as always I
remind counselors that um uh if you do
have an interest then please declare it
um before the matter is
discussed um I have no urgent matters um
brought
forward and um there are no items in
part two tonight so no need to vote on
that uh and without further Ado let's
move uh straight to the section1 officer
um qbr to yes thank you chair if if we
can start with the nonanal information
so Anna we'll just leave off with the
service reports reports two thank you
and so here are the highlights um just
as I was getting used to the SI for
family group that we are compared with
they've G to change them so this is the
new map of the groups that we are um
compared to when we um do benchmarking
15 councils um they are they have
statistical characteristics similar to
ours to
torage and they range for in location
Cumbria North the yire to the north
boards and Kent and there are more in
Devon we're compared to more in Devon
than we were
before so theme one the local economy
the refurbished Bell coat was replaced
on Market house in hington early on a
Sunday morning and I know the estate's
manager was hoping that it did not
attract any crowds but it was noticed
and caused quite a stir on social media
Business Report has continued across
North Devon with Tor and North Devon
Council working in Partnership the
support includes grants onetoone
meetings and workshops and then thinking
about improvements for theme one the
number of people um claiming Universal
Credit has actually gone up since qbr 1
and it's still a challenge to get people
into work and encourage investment in
year round jobs I'm guessing a lot of
our jobs are um seasonal which is why
this an issue and um just a good news
this was a a bit of a good news story
the average earnings um which is in the
qbr has gone up since last last year uh
the latest figures are 2022 for the year
and um we compare quite well with our
within our family
group um communities Heth and housing
the rebuild of Victoria Park play area
has been designed tendered and will be
delivered hopefully in the winter
funding for that has come from various
sources including the government's rural
Pro Prosperity fund the bord bridge
trust and bidford Town Council active
torage have a number of initiatives to
get residents in tes fit and happy
including Moonlight swims in torington
which I believe have proved very
popular and then thinking about
improvements for theme two um along with
other districts in Devon torage doesn't
provide um the number of affordable
houses that they would like to and that
other councils do in our group and I
know that the planning team are
monitoring the challenges of trying to
deliver affordable
housing
and theme three our environment and our
future Northern borrows have been busy
asking for volunteers to help with
conservation
work um this summer and there was a new
toy
Library which were uh people were able
to enjoy the beach in a more sustainable
Way by
borrowing um
equipment and the recycling rates in TD
remain high because we send the third
lowest tonnage of waste to landfill or
incineration in our group of
councils and lastly theme four our
Council the consultation for the
Strategic plan has had a reasonable
response with nearly half of the
comments relating to restoring the train
line Froman B to bford other subjects
covered in the comments are housing the
environment and town
centers uh the throwback Thursday post
on social media are get encourag
residents reminiscing about Times Gone
by creating positive engagement
a team from torich spent the day
networking with other councils in the
region at the Devon Association of local
councils in
ex and the name that Lori competition
was a great success and even made it
onto
Spotlight and looking at Trends the prea
planning process is
improving uh with the number of days
from ballage to response going down
month by month and hopefully that will
continue to
improve into the next
yeah so I can go straight onto the
finance there um so at the end of so
when we were here two three months ago
we only had information that related to
the first three months of the financial
year well now we've got the numbers as
well for July August and September the
positions becoming um much clearer so
back at the end of quarter one we're
anticipating an underspend of 472,000 as
the um interest rece as the cash
received on our interest received on our
cash balances was very high um since
then we're now looking to be broadly
speaking on balance so with this with a
a small um overspend that's predicted
and I'll and I'll go through a few
slides that that simply pulls out some
tables from the report you've seen
already which explains in Greater detail
um where these changes have come from
this first table just shows the um the
anticipated over spend um based upon the
organization char
and the key and the key tables there are
to the right of the narrative around
service responsibilities so it's the
year end and that's the that's the key
one
there obviously you can see that most of
the underspend are in GX office head of
legal and governance and finance
managers but it's the head of
communities in place that picks up a lot
of the over spends and that's partly
just because they have the respons they
have a lot of Staffing there and they
have the property responsibilities as
well they pick up a lot of those
areas so this just shows in bullet point
form um the details of some of the F
adverse and favorable um variances um so
this slide and the next which provides a
bit more narrative as well so the staff
cost hasn't changed particularly we're
still anticipating the staff the same
staff pay award at quarter two as we
were at quarter one although now there's
significant agency costs which have
being built in also um at quar of one we
mentioned the computer soft Ware and
some of the contract cleaning costs but
some of the new items there that are now
coming along relate to repairs and
maintenance for for for properties um
and some changes to car park fees which
I'll go through a bit more detail um in
terms of the favorable variances there's
no change there in terms of Bank
interest but we are showing another
300,000 additional receipts in Grants
from either central government or other
local authorities I do say now we're
building in some of the savings from the
cost of capital financing as it doesn't
appear that some of those there's going
to be a lot of spend on those schemes in
the current
year so yeah this this shows again but
with a bit more narrative attached to it
some explanation behind some of the over
and over spends um but I'll just talk
about car parking for a moment because
because even though it suggests um that
they're going to be under under budget
in reality there's still significant
increases from the last two years the
car parking in
it's just that there was an increase of
budget of 300,000 between 2223 and
2324 so a big increase in Target that
there probably not going to achieve but
it's still positive news on the
whole yes and of course um there's still
the issue of inflation generally which
is having an impact um as at the end of
quarter one there was still a hope that
planning income would come back on
budget um now that now that there is
less confidence of that and they do
think they'll be they'll be spend in
terms of planning
inome and this the table just shows
those P income lines so and of course
there's going to be greater variability
for the most part to do with our income
streams that we receive so the largest
is car parking income so even though
we're above budget for um or below
budget sorry for for those ad hoc
tickets we are over budget for season
tickets so broadly speaking on balance
um the second largest item relates to
Garden waste which is broadly on budget
the third largest item is rental income
which is reassuringly um over budget but
those are those key numbers um there and
of course we report them Che partly
because they're big numbers but also
because they're more variable than other
sources of
funding so that top table just shows our
our salaries budgets so even though it
would appear that we're we're under
budget there's still significant costs
still to come through from from agencies
overall um there will still be increased
costs for starting when start payward is
G
through that second table on this slide
um shows the capital approvals um for
this year and within the program
generally so that's that large 42
million pounds figure that you see there
which brings in all the large Capital
schemes like the the operational Center
um and the Apple Innovation Center um
the second ofn is the spend in year and
that's jumped up a lot between quarter
one and Quarter Two that as we purchased
additional vehicles um and also we
completed spend on on Sully house and of
course there's the ongoing spend on the
disable facili for as well although
still a lot of spend to go a lot of that
big spend probably will be occurring in
the next financial year rather than this
financial year as was originally
anticipated and this table just it's
it's important to remind to remind you
all about our financial health and
residents generally and its reserves
that that are a key part of that so this
shows um the original budgeted taking
Reserve um as at the start of the year
but of course you may find that for
example areas like agents with backfill
or apprentices we could thought down
upon over the course of the as as we
close the accounts for this year but at
the moment we don't show any anticipated
take there key numbers within there of
course in terms of our revenue revenue
reserves are the the monies put aside to
support capital investment which is the
8 million figure towards the bottom of
the table um and also of course the
transition to Government funding Reserve
at just over 2 million which we use to
to help assist with with um budgetary
deficits and then this last slide just
for the government's purposes shows you
where our cash balances are lent out to
at the moment it shows that they're
compliant with our treasury management
policy and it also gives you an
indication of the the interest we
received thank
you
um before we go on to the specific uh
written questions are there any um
general questions uh based on the
presentation we just
heard it all fairly
um fairly strict for and easy to follow
and um also the
um
um in general terms um I I think the the
figures are looking sort of they're not
they're not sort of giving one a
complete um sess nights and heart
attacks
um uh never be complacent but um Council
C I was just wondering how many
responses you had to the consultation at
moment um there 37 responses one more
came in this evening I haven't managed
to look at it yet um so 37 in total 16
have been about the railway nine about
housing um six about renewable energy
six about town centers how many did we
get um at the last
coun Well we'd have to have a look we
did have a few more from the last one I
have been looking at them but there was
more from Parish councils we haven't had
any from Paris councils as yet we do
still have a week none at allone parish
councils as yet across the whole of Tor
you've had no have you when were the
parish council's asked for their
response and they as far as I know it's
been advertised and I've actually sent
out an email and to the parish clerks um
because at the last B the town council
meeting it was discussed um that they
didn't know that yeah why haven't they
been invited to I check on the email
date but I sent and I have actually had
a response from the I think it was the
Bri town clerk that I've been conversing
with and he did say that it was about
two weeks ago I sent out a
reminder as of two weeks ago two of my
parishes hadn't received had received
any notification I check on the date
that I sent the email I'm not sure about
when it
was we also sent out a number of invites
to the are advisories through go
delivery that went to every Parish
Council so we use that system it went
for okay
um if we've I think we might need just
do a we need to do a check on that
actually because if if U for some reason
the Clarks have not received the the
consultation then um we may have to make
her advice that there is some possibly
some some
delay the tool we use and the tool that
comms use um we can see if they've
received it we can see if they've opened
it if they've clicked on the link so we
can if you provide us with the parishes
that you worried about we can take a
look at that okay I'm third of October
PR the first um press release out all
parishes and then I think it was chased
up after that as well we've had an
email that's fine um thank you very much
we will
um could all counselors here just as a
as a as a as a random sample could you
please check with
your Parish
Clarks the rural ones and in the towns
town clerk can we just check that they
actually they don't want to comment
that's their business and it's not us
it's not our business to tell them they
got a comment we just need to know
though that they have actually had that
um and they and they've actually done
something with it because the Clarks are
not the authority counselors are and it
needs to be brought to the attention of
c um found Parish counsel but I got a
bit of a blank look also when I looked
yeah um I'm just a little bit concerned
that uh the scheduling of
responses and the schedule of their
committee meetings uh to discuss these
things uh maybe we need to be giving
town and Parish councils a little longer
um you know we I don't know about
everybody else but we've moved from um
sort of monthly meetings to six weekly
meetings um to try and be more efficient
uh but sometimes obviously things take a
bit longer to go through the system so
um I think it's worthwhile finding out
and getting a definitive answer from the
town clks as to whether they actually
been able to put it on an agenda for
discussion to feedback
results because um our Northern mayor is
here and sorry who's you know we haven't
been discussed it at Northern have we no
no so is that is that because you you
chose not to discuss it which is your
business or because you haven't actually
it hasn't actually been on featured on a
a council agenda and the town Clark sets
the agenda we need to make
sure
so we have a full council meeting next
week so the agenda will be going out
this week I should be looking at the
agenda so yeah so
we but then that's got to go on the
agenda and if you're going to formulate
a a for or
against you know whether there is the
time in the for council meeting to
actually debate that appropriately is
questionable okay okay I guess that's
what we give a six week period of
consultation and email it helps the
morning after the full Council to give
all Parish CLS that opportunity um is
the district council we're in quite a
tight time frame but indeed my my
concern was that they may not have
received it now this could be an
efficiency business but
certainly I've spoken to two coun two
Clarks who said they hadn't received
anything from us not that long ago um
now if that is the case then that is an
issue with with us at our end if but as
long as they've had it then um what they
do with it is their
business tell us a little them sorry
just information is in new he doesn't
know is when you say no responses from
councelors are we supposed to respond as
a councel or as individual counselors
and if we try to respond as an
individual Council will we then a member
of the public you can you can they P
response from from from anybody um but
specifically the town and Parish
councilors have been invited to um are
part of the consultation um and normally
we would see some input and we'd
certainly be aware that that the town
and Parish councils have discussed it
even if they' come up with nothing to
say
but you can
still make a contribution whether you do
it as an
individual um so problem right um straw
poll can tomorrow can you just speak to
your your relevant um Clarks and just
find out did have they had it and have
they discussed it or are they planning
to discuss it I said we can't tell them
that they've got to discuss it but um
the absence of comment is is slightly
concerning um that and
um if the consultation is to have
credibility then we want to have a sign
that it's been widely considered other
than there is evidence at the moment
that certain specific interest groups
have leftt on to it um but um actually
there's an awful lot in there other than
just one or two um specific things um
okay um
yes just just a followup question just
on the the new peer group been on the
affordable housing I just wonder if
there's any that are doing anything
differently the affordable housing where
they're doing something that we might
learn from whether there's any learns in
that group that's not an answer for now
but it's just yeah I'll have a look at
that they're brand new and I have been
looking at some of their websites yes
and so I'll continue to see if there is
you work with thanks I'm going to chip
something in about that later on when we
come
to
down um continuing on the uh QB uh
moving to the written uh questions that
were
submitted um and I went read because
you've all hopefully you've all seen
I've now been I've got a paper copy with
you've all seen the the responses uh in
the
supplement um so the first question from
councelor Bright uh asking about more
more information about reduction in
parking income um mentioned on page
three and four of the qbr and uh with a
further insight into our statistics and
there we have a
response
um
are you happy with that response yeah
yeah I just better check it because you
know we're going to have a lot of
Revenue we got to know about it well
absolutely um
and I think it's a I think it's a very
valad thing especially you know in the
in the other areas of discussion where
there's been we've had discussions about
um in in in other committees and indeed
it was as a notice of motion and I know
it's coming it'll be coming back to CNR
or whatever where we've discussed about
um um the use of car Parks or Charities
Etc in fact I think counc was was put
put that forward it it's a worthless
discussion unless there's actually
pounds and Pence attached to it you need
to know you need to know the figures
otherwise you're just talking about soft
principle um and actually how how much
uh and what would it cost um because
that's actually counselors what we need
to know is what is the cost real cost
can we afford it are we prepared to take
the pain so um this sort of question is
important and and and thank you for it
um I miss
the sorry I've
been I've been given I've been given a a
copy that was backto back printed I
don't have that luxury at home and so I
missed it I'm very sorry right um so um
but you're happy with that one the thing
we were dealing with that one okay um
going to the start of the uh list thank
you very much um first of all question
from councelor Elliot um number of total
number or the average of agency staff um
for vacant posts and the answer there
currently got 11 and then
um goes on to say that there it qbr
shows that we've got over 20 post vacant
uh how long has been the longest one
vacant and what is the problem with
filling them uh is nobody applying for
them question mark or is no one suitable
or qualified for the roles applying and
there we have the
answers um and then he goes on to ask
why vacancies in the refu collection are
area we're not included and again the
answer we've I've heard that one before
and it there's inevitably in that area
there's a lot of shortterm churn uh in
in in posts and it it doesn't
necessarily give you a a a good feel for
the long-term uh situation uh but then
just as we're on it what is the number
of refuges
vacancies um and um there we have the
answers again again there's a total of
13 covering Grounds Maintenance and
waste um seven uh have new started
processes in place um people being
checked Etc and there are still six
currently advertised uh councilor are
you happy with those responses do you
have yes CH all the questions are
answered
good uh thank you uh moving on question
from Mr
Harper uh budget monitoring
[Music]
um sorry it's linked to the agencies I
didn't know if we've got an enabling
officer appointed
yet not yet
sure going it's going through the
internal process to put together the job
description and to a job evaluation
process and I was wondering about the
legal team what are the vacancies there
and um when will they be we don't have a
legal services manager currently yeah is
that out um are we using some external
resource to to backfill we've had
problems in the past recruiting to Legal
posts as we've had with many
professional
posts well we are going to we are going
to actually we having a look at the the
structure yeah imagine the costs for a
legal
um agency that would be a lot of money
the council if we haven't got someone in
P yeah but it it's very um I mean just
thinking as we recruited to the to that
um to that post last time uh it is very
difficult to find let's call it um um
professional qualified people
professionally qualified people of that
of that style it it's really difficult
to to to attract them um here a mix
of um
geography um um other professional
opportunities
elsewhere um professional earning
opportunities elsewhere um it's it's
diff I
mean it took us a long time to to to
fill it last time didn't it yeah and
with some roles like how you can't
obviously remotely so as the chair is
saying you could have a job paid at the
London wage rate and live in in this
area we rate wage rates as we saw much
lower so that's some part of the problem
with some of these particular
ring
um have you got any anything that's but
yeah I mean it's it's a good point it's
um with with the more specialist roles
uh it it Rec recruitment is is a problem
as we know uh Right Moving on uh to Mr
AR's first question on budget
monitoring um with the the forecast uh
deficit at the end of finan year as we
saw small small deficit
9,000
um and yet um during period two you say
you know we're seeing a shortfall of 497
th000 um followed by a surplus of
472,000
um is one off or will things such as
staff cost impact throughout the
financial year and uh the answer there
much as actually was given in the
presentation um you happy with it I'm
more than happy with it the only thing
what I'm interested in is the fact that
c tax isn't shown on The Ledger until
the end of the
year
um yes yeah thank you it's just the way
that the income's profile and I think
partly it's I've gone back to this first
table and it's the first two columns I
think that pick up upon your initial
question but obviously um and that's the
sort of the actual deficit as at month
six if you like but in a sense that
isn't the most interesting number it's
still useful information to you all but
it doesn't actually predict what the PO
position is going to be for the year you
have to move across the columns in order
to get to that so I think hopefully
that's the explanation proba just
provides an additional perspective on
there do we face as well figures all of
the anticipated outturn figures are are
profile
um right we've done councelor Bright's
one um and then um moving to Mr
dengate
um Barber and pilotage a a familiar
theme um uh in in this committee um
pointing out that the average Quarter
Two income over the last three
years uh has been Circa 38.5 th000 um
against an average budget over the same
period of just over
40,000 um however this quarters income
is only
75% uh of this three-year Trend and yet
the budget is 57% of the bend Trend he
asks what is the mythology being applied
to the budget forecasting uh for 2324
and the answer is we see that
um
um which
in
um covers the increase in pilotage um
and the also the um increase in in
Harbor pet are you happy uh with that
and then goes on in in a lot of detail
um and how
um well in in in that detail are you are
you happy with the response happy with
that I mean you can work only work with
the numbers you have and the trend is
still down but it's a it's a helpful
answer so thank you it does explain that
um varant yeah I liked your I I was
particularly interested in your second
question
uh which is what needs to be done to
encourage big ships back or is this not
possible what plans are in place to
increase the harbor income from
alternative sources there's a big
there's a big question here because
there is
a been relatively new on the council
that there is a tendency of people to
view things through the lens of the
status quo that that's how it always was
and that's how it should be um well
sound Shi and things change and we've
been tinkering at this for a while on
the whole harbor side that the the
business model down
there looks from a statistical point of
view certainly when I whilst I've been
sitting on this committee and I've been
looking at qbr report Etc the business
model has
changed um and that comes stage when you
have to and it's and it's it's it's all
shortterm um blips or is this a a
long-term enduring Trend that there is a
change and and um the point at which you
you realize that actually the SS have
shifted and therefore you need to take a
different View and the view will be
different to how it's been 50 for the
last 50 years or whatever um and um so
this was a very interesting um uh
response
um
optimistic um asking for another let's
see for another
year
[Music]
um you have a review on that well the
six Monon review in June is is good but
I still think that's a little way off um
I think shifting Sands is a or sand
shifting is quite an interesting phrase
if you're looking at
dredging um but you know it is a
question um that I think
probably does warrant some some thinking
through and we obviously have the S
strategy in mind as well so it it may
just be we've got to accept that you
know past dis one country and something
s changed the chief executive just
pointed out to me that and in fact it's
a an Miss mission in the last minutes
that I approved in that in the minutes
it stated from our last meeting that I
was going to speak to the chair of the
har board with regard the whole of the
thing but that didn't didn't appear in
our action list and actually should
could have appeared in the action list
and as a result I apologize um members
of the committee that I have missed that
and I've not done that today I I will do
so um
because this again is is all all goes
back into in into the the whole Harbor
board um business um and I I I I think
certainly that you know there's
some there is a need for for um people
to decide whether there's actually
been whether there is a fundamental
shift in um business style down there if
that's the right word uh and if that's
the case then we as a council should be
looking looking at it differently as
opposed to rather expecting the same old
income streams suddenly to come good
again um and
um um the you know and there are there
there are there are people inevitably
who are very close to uh the
organization down there who will take an
optimistic view um that is not
necessarily the view that we have to
take um but I will discuss with the
chair of the haror board and I apologize
that I have not done that I should have
done to uh yes
um yeah um
yeah the list of possible um income
streams at the bottom looks a bit sort
of optimistic to me really um but also I
just wanted to ask about the appor
maritime Innovation Center bringing
additional shipping could someone
explain how that would be bringing in
additional shipping and understood that
the Maritime Center will be a sort of
research basically research
function be on go directly I I didn't
write the comments chair so um I guess
it's it's attracting um a lot of
attention
so being um something on on the water I
suspect we've had um contact from people
interested so I don't know the specific
background to that comment but we can
find out from the har
[Music]
master I think as we probably all all
know here I think that it's all probably
far too early
to pin a sort of financial sort of um
tick on it um yeah quite
uh thank you very much
um the harbor is an interesting
conundrum because ever since I became a
counselor five years ago we were talking
about the viability in the future of um
the harbor uh the role of the Harbor
Master
did we need a crane or not did we need
to dredge or not and it all seemed to be
um uh we'll go and report back to you
and I'm not sure if we ever I can
remember one discussion with regard to
the status of the port and the fact that
uh you couldn't just say we're not
having any it we're not having anymore
because it's awarded a legal status so I
think there's some things that we really
do need to look into um and yes it's a
great thing that we have a harbor maybe
but not if it's constantly costing us
year on year additional money and if we
cannot make it viable we need to
actually start talking about how we can
protect uh ourselves from ongoing
Financial commitments so I think it's
it's time to bite the bullet actually
and actually start talking about are
these proposals viable or or are they
wishful thinking um and I might be
making myself very unpopular but the
issue for me is we have a river we have
a port let's find out what we can do
with it and not just hope that we'll
suddenly have China clay moving back in
here yeah and I just endorsed that I've
been on now six years and it just seems
to be a
recurring that we keep coming back and
we'll do this we'll do this we do this
but we never actually stopped to say
have we yes and I mean the concept is as
you AB can say and to especially to to
you know many um very loyal bord um
people the concept that it might not be
viable is absolute sacr to to to some
well I'm afraid it's our job to be you
know uh rather cold and realistic in
looking at it the Council of about just
um the the group who's been in touch
with the with the council
um out
title
Heritage yeah um who are currently
apping for Heritage Harvest stat is for
bit good har because I think there's
a there's a should be or that is a
recognition of the fact that torage is
like links everywhere from the the
seethrough appor B all the way up to
toron um well T but were Bron and I
there and there's a lot of volunteer
groups who are very interested in
promoting and working with the har to
make it to look at it differently I
think um you know the that maybe the
commercial
um maybe the commercial shipping is not
the same maybe the has China clay and
and Timber has has altered but the value
of the torage to the whole area in terms
of Heritage and tourism and everything
else is hugely important and I think
it's something something
that
um really needs discussing with the
council and um and this group and the
harbor board
um to see just what I'm very I'm feeling
very uncomfortable talking because of
saying that I'm not supposed to
challenge anything that's no not do not
do not it's not challenging to to to say
that so I don't know
to accept that everybody's talking about
the harb so I feel
like no problem they're making they've
been making um approaches to the council
um for some weeks now there's a a big
group um of interested parties um that
are really very very keen to work with
torge and um develop the harbor not
necessarily in the way that it's been
developed in the past still used in the
past but to enhance the value of that to
the whole
area um not just the that appor and
um I I don't
know I think Council CRA is going to
speak because you you you you you
you any very reasonbly um on this yeah
and I think it's it's very important
obviously the sort of first paragraph in
the answer is the bord is kept at 90
meter and getting commercial shipping it
is
increasingly huge ships so we do have to
look at that Leisure educational uses um
and that does mean reflecting a bit more
on the on the Heritage the past use of
it because obviously we're lucky that
many many areas they've just got
historic ports we you know we've got a
working port and we've put a find ways
of uh making making it pay for itself
but also uh making it pay for the area
and what in in response to what you and
thank you very much for for raising that
councilor about the what I would say is
that that initiative is part of the
wider discussion that needs to take
place it can't but the and where the
where they had issue the other night at
for Council is that there
was a suggestion that it should be
looked at in isolation well it actually
needs to be look at as part of the whole
analysis of the harbor side the
commercial side the value of the value
not only in in in cost terms but also in
cultural terms of of the Heritage side
so it is a decision that is taken in the
whole um if people continue to come
forward and ask us to look at one
specific project like that we will
continue to resisted because you need to
look at the whole sum and the whole sum
includes commercially there are
suggestions that the the the harbor may
not be May no longer be viable so
therefore as part of that
discussion one looks at the opportunity
for Heritage and whe whether that can be
built up and can that be justified etc
etc so all I'm saying is that when we
when it's looked at it needs to be
looked at in the round otherwise we
can't do business in a council like this
where we we're actually trying to look
at individual little things without
actually looking at all the other things
that that impact with it so it
absolutely um there is a you know there
is a a a very good um case to be made
there I'm not making any judgment as to
as to its merits or strengths and that
needs to be made as an option possibly
to fill some of the the vacuum um VI
viable wise at the moment Council bright
thank you CH yeah so what where's the
next process to start this instigating a
review of the proper usage of the the
harbor what what's the next step the
next the next step is the thing that I
have not
done the next step is
and uh is for me first of all to discuss
it on a onetoone basis with the chair of
the harbor board to see if the harbor
board are prepared to
actually pick this ball up and run with
it and in in other words not just be
oversight of the status quo but actually
to be prepared to sit back and look at
um the the the whole of the situation
there and the future of it and the
viability and either commercially in
pounds and Pence or you're going to
justify it through other means if it can
be uh and if um the chair of the Harvard
board is feels that uh they're not
prepared to take that on then this
committee Will May well make
recommendations as
to that being um but that'll have to be
a council um decision it's it's not for
us to to take that decision but just a
quick follow on um is the har got a
specific remit that might stop it from
being able to say look at tourism or
whatever I don't know what the actual re
specifically is is it purely industrial
re I was just going to ask because can
we have a look at the constitution of
the all the board constitution of the
hard board is in the
Constitution it'll be on your to anybody
look at the or Constitution so it's in
the harbor board is a working working
group that reports to CNR for decision
Mak and it's conly constituted within
the council's Constitution so that's why
it's uh set up and that's why the chair
our chair here is going to speak to the
chair of the har
board um so um yeah I'm I'm um and
indeed this this question here actually
strengthens my
um um my discussion that I can have with
with chair of the H board thank you I
will report back uh councilors um but um
there there is um
um okay I was
just I was just wondering thinking back
to the dra strategic plan whether it
might be an action as part of the local
economy the review
the um use of the
harbor that maybe thought when we come
to
[Music]
agree yeah any as we said earlier
anybody can make any um responsive to
the consultation process there's not
directly mentioned in our draft at the
momently talking with about
all the councilors around the table part
of that uh discussion and debate and
approved the the draft so again it comes
when that comes back to full councel
because and if it if it if it doesn't
here in the Strategic it doesn't mean
that it doesn't happen so it doesn't
just because it's not in the Strategic
plan doesn't exclude it from from
happening but um potentially there's
quite a major piece of work there yeah
um and quite a
controversial yes
uh I've got um I've got the terms the
reference to the harbor board here
it's received reports from the
operational services manager on issues
affecting management of the harbor
consider such issues make recommendation
as appropriate to CNR establish and
maintain strong links with Harbor users
the community and other stakeholders
uphold principles of governance set out
in Department of Transport something or
other and to participate in reviews of
council policies so far as it affects
food father so doesn't seem to have
[Music]
absolute a lot of their work is
concerned
with
operational oversight the actual
functioning of what's in place um I I'll
I'll um um discuss a cic and then um I
will um report back um is the answer for
him um I just my you know the reason I
raised it was that I think that the
foundation for the discussion is a
financial one we are here to scrutinize
our QV yeah and we have
watched over a period of time um ongoing
costs to the local
Authority and that's what we should be
scrutinizing and say we hear and read
your comments but uh we're not really
confident
that this is the solution you know what
are your plans for the future and I
think that's the starting point for the
discussion because you can't keep on
propping up something um or can you
would it be the will of the community
that we serve to actually subsidize that
because they want to maintain
so two questions really and both ways
it's Financial yeah because at the end
of the day you as you just use the word
subsidize sub Subs subsidy is Cash is
money um it's got to come from somewhere
else so if there's some other
theme so Heritage rather than
commercial fine but that will come cost
and that will be for Council decide
whether that is Affordable um Etc but I
think absolutely I hear your point that
from our point of view from a scrutiny
point of view actually especially as
it's gone on and on and on we are it is
fair and right that actually we put a
flag up and
say my my only caution if you forgive me
coming back is that you
need the appropriate legal advice as to
the status of the court and the
authority about what we are obligated to
do and I'm sure
Steve um Chief exac is uh conversant
with that and if not he excellent
members of Staff who can help in find
that and again that is not our concern
no that that is something that a review
would of course you know that would be
one of their their starting point but
that's we're not conducting that review
and all we're quite right I understand
entirely agree thank you councilor one
one last
sorry I'm very nervous about saying
anything out loud but I'm also very
nervous about missing an opportunity to
say things when the opportunity arises
but um at risk of being very
controversial other
Harbors um Finance Harbor
activities because by you having the
income of the car park of the key
allocated to them and I have been told
previously that that's legally and I
don't
know that that should be happening in b
if it were then the harbor wouldn't
be it's I mean you can say well that's
Ming
P yeah but again you look at the just
it's just an accounting entry thek
income is the park income but I'm saying
that is how they balance their book
ultimately it's it's all our taxpayers
money and you know we're not talking
about a different company we're talking
about whether whether the the money is
you know going in through the harbor
books or whether it's actually coming
direct um ultimately it is taxpayer
money and that is our legal
responsibility around this table to um
be yeah guardians of that I think uh
kind of in response I think some the way
some authorities are structured they
might have a port company back to New so
then there is kind of a ring and around
certain things uh but the Tor it's said
this all the income is all the income or
expenditure of the
council
um thank you for that I've got more than
enough guidance to um now um get around
to having a discussion with the chair of
Harbor board I apologize again for not
having done so so far actually I'm I'm
better place now to have that
conversation uh and I will come back to
you um
um and then we move on um with our
written uh questions and we are on to
theme four from councelor Elliot again
um and um he asks
uh again what incentives and schemes are
in place for staff retention of which
SAR H HR manager produces um uh the list
of various um uh incentives and schemes
there which are uh very typical I think
to to um other local employers um
um local
government there there are is is is
different from um private business
and private business uh have much more
flexibility over Financial
incentivization bonuses extra etc etc
within local government we don't have
that and therefore one has to work on on
all the other areas of of of um uh
incentivization
um are you happy Council Elliott with
the list that you've got there yes chair
yes that the only reason I've been
targeting staff is because I I agency
staff obviously cost a lot of money of
course and I noticed on qb1 it was a
23 vacant post and 20 21 I think for
this time so I just sort of wondered if
there was
any issues going on but everything all
seems to be all me all me questions and
that all have satisfactory
answered um and uh you had a follow on
there on that basis of um um the
shortage of hgv drivers um and uh
Richard haste comes back to say that um
uh he now is at a full compliment um and
has also just taken on an apprentice on
hgv um happy with that
yes um good that ends the um written
questions and to those who have um
taking the time to put those questions
forward thank you as always very much um
um finally there's Christmas hamper as
well
list you did Christmas hamper you for
the STA oh yeah sorry
[Laughter]
I'm everyone with a
thank you sounds a Del I just wonder why
we not getting people joining
orang a good range of
incentives yeah so the question is why
aren we
attracting and what is the flexy time
like how how much are people allowed to
work from
home if you recall if you look at the
forward plan I ha ha managers do to
report at the next meeting
rather might give some the long
details
um are you are you happy to hold up um
so um then let's move on to
consideration of the board
plan um agenda item
nine uh as I said we were just left with
qbr 2 today um
we have a um review of the qbr process
including Recruitment and
Retention um listed for um there and
then we've got presentations on the
draft Northern Devon economic strategy
um enforcement planning and
environmental and the slipped uh report
um on the Strategic Management plan and
um do we now think that we've got too
much in
that yeah it does seem a little bit
heavy it doesn't
it
[Music]
um the um realistically we're looking at
possibly slipping something out into
cycle seven I Su
[Music]
um I stress that we have a discussion
with each other's offices with yourself
yeah uh I know draft Northern B Strate
economic strategy been
done North North so not quite sure
exactly where we are but I think that
might be a little bit later so I guess
if we have
a generally counselors I'm I'm concerned
that cycle 6 12 of December is looking
um over full um and I I know note your
eagerness for nice long meetings in
excessive through out um but um uh one's
enthusiasm and time and concentration um
on something if we go on too long
inevitably begins to wne and a lot of
these require a lot of effort uh put in
by officers um and they deserve our full
attention when they do come to us
um and I will um together with the chief
executive
um we we will go through each of those
and look at what apps can slip um I
think we've got one too many things in
that um now um and caused by the the
slip into it of the Strategic asset
Asset Management um looking
forward there are
two specific subjects that
uh I would suggest to you that it would
be useful for us to hear from officers
about um both um
require
some explanation to us briefing to us as
to what is the actual format and rules
to be followed and then to look at what
situation is here with us in torich one
of which came up earlier this evening
and that that is um the affordable
housing limits or levels and that is
there's quite a
complex um system that drives this a and
then viability um um issues later on Etc
and we need to understand that first so
that needs to be um and and then once
you've had the background of of how it
works then we actually look at what
figures we're achieving and we can then
have a discussion as to whether uh we
have concern that we are that um because
we we know we are below the percentage
level that we as a council set um and um
uh people's thinking on on on
that well I I was just wondering whether
we've got an update when the housing
strategy might be possible to because
obviously that would fit quite it it
it I thought about that but because I've
got something else that that's it
doesn't it can be looked at separate
from the housing strategy because this
is actually this is a a a
um a pol a policy issue within with with
within the planning process it's not
actually it's not affected by strategy
so much because actually it's working to
figures which have been laid down
already there is a process there which
so I don't think it it comes into
achieving the and so that's why we could
look we could potentially look at it in
isolation uh rather than necessary
um do people think that that would be a
a useful thing to to to learn more
about affordable housing always comes up
well I mean affordable housing is is on
the priorities
absolutely and I mean this is specific
linked to the the um the quotas of
affordable housing which are required by
certain developments Etc uh which are at
a fixed percentage and yet we we fall
well short of actually what we managed
to deliver and we need to understand the
mechanism that goes on behind it first
and then be able to have a discussion
with informed officers as to why we're
not getting anywhere near that that
figure
um would that
be we have obviously the working a move
towards a new local
plan um and affordable housing would be
obviously key um subject within that for
both us and our neighbors in North Deon
that we're working together with I think
sometimes it's about awareness sessions
of what does viability mean um you know
we've already got questions being asked
about District valuers as opposed to
Independent valuers for looking at our
housing schemes
um it's what people's knowledge is what
does affordable mean affordable to me
might not be the same as affordable to
my fellow counselor here and it's really
understanding the um language we use
when we're talking about affordable
housing is it affordable to buy
affordable to
rent does it is it impacted by the
inability to our our local housing
allowance to cover the rent that people
have shortfalls immediately they go into
the house and they have to find that on
top of everything else all the other
expenses they have so I think
sometimes perhaps we need to be not
looking at it as a a thing to scrutinize
but a thing to educate and to share with
our counselors we used to do bite-size
training for people and I think those
are are really quite useful I think if
you want to look at affordable housing
you need to look at the whole agenda
because there are significant issues
around housing for young people housing
for people with support needs and these
are big issues that are coming up that
our partnership working with the council
is uh
significant um so I personally don't
necessarily think affordable housing as
a subject on its own here is
useful but that might just be
me I think it's also when talking about
affordable homes is also to bring into
that the so social homes because
obviously you've only got three types of
ownership you've got your open market
the affordable and the social and it's
it's important to get the right mix of
that because obviously we've got a lot
of housing associations in the area also
you've got community land that all sorts
of brands of housing get that entirely
but coming back to the argument that you
using with the harbor board actually as
an act of scrutiny currently there are
criteria laid down
on amount affordable housing and what
affordable housing in a technical
planning point of view that's not I'm
not looking I want to know at the moment
there are requirements laid upon the
planning process here about delivery of
affordable housing in terms of numbers
of units per whatever and they are set
at you know if it if it's for purchase
x% below the market rate Etc it's a
different argument to say whether that
is right or not what I want to know at
the moment is or I understand at the
moment that we fall well short of what
we say we should be delivering on that
from a technical point of view put aside
the the moral discussions or or or
anything like that and I would like to
understand better why we
don't uh we don't achieve um our
percentage uh level of affordable
housing which sorry to Har on about it
but the viability is an issue that we
allow developers to look at the
viability during the planning or
delivery of the game and actually come
back to us you know that but these
people don't necessarily and that's why
we need we need that's why I said we
need to look at information sharing
educating rather than that's not
scrutiny scrutiny for me is where we've
got a system that is uh set out and it's
we think it's not working and then we
investigate it well we do have a system
that set out we should be providing 30%
of affordable housing and we don't but
we know we should be asking why don't
why why not we know we're open to Legal
challenge if you feel that's enough for
a subject for a meeting fine but these
are these are just those are all
different reasons that can be explained
to to us but I think sorry perhaps I
make assumptions that people are convers
with those think I think situ
possibly perhaps people I don't know
around the table are we all aware of the
the challenges of viability
and how
developers actually ask for a reduction
in the number of bable housing that does
everybody understand the principles of
that I think different see that when you
have a metric that you have to Aspire
too yeah they are important but you
still have to metric yeah and the
question is is the metric right yeah
yeah really because the thing about
performance in dat you get the wrong one
in place it drives behavior in the wrong
way yeah but that is the that's the
local plan that dictated that Matrix for
how what the percentage of you know for
developments over a certain amount
you've got to have this so that is the
mat we had so that's what we're so we
scrutinizing the local
plan which is
you know not sure that's
quite then well
we I no objection you know yeah Lee
don't think I'm
I'm objecting to it but I just think you
know I think it I think it's a it's a
it's a worthwhile thing to ask officers
to brief us on what is the current
system what are the current problem and
and how much do we we miss that by and
what is causing that
why um because it may well be as a
result that is then something that we
want to make sure is fed into the local
plan review uh and it can be a comment
from this committee because it's an
internal thing as as Steve said there is
there there their metric set out um
and when actually we don't deliver on
that
um we need to we need we should be
asking why not could we include the to
find out more about the role of this
enabling Offa which we're waiting for
because we're told that that's holding
us back from bringing forward Community
Land Trust so maybe that would be part
of how we that's possibly part of the
the the the the solution it's it's um
okay yeah because I don't fully
understand what the role is of the
enabling officer so it'd be good to find
out how that would help develop and
bring forward more affordable or social
housing I mean I thought the one of the
problems with the affordable housing or
allowing us to actually achieve our
thresholds is that the
national plan and policy framework
actually undermines it and says that in
certain scenarios you're allowed 0%
affordable housing and then you can't
really do much with that
situation that is all part of I if that
is the case that is all part of the
brief you're going to
get because you said well you you you
you thought but you're not quite sure
well we need to we need to speak to
somebody who's actually a subject matter
expert in the area um because there's a
affordable housing lack of difficulties
with is something that's banded around
almost at every opportunity and I think
we just have we need to have better
quality
understanding of the issues that are
being faced uh by officers um uh Etc and
I don't I think that's that would be
good for our instruction and then would
allow us to actually take a view as to
whether it's necessary to to take
anything better or not so it's a
briefing session it' be a briefing
absolutely but then with the ability
then to have discussion with the AER as
a result of that briefing we should take
quite happily take briefs um that's the
overviews I would add to
that the question of empty
properties uh which again we have we
frequently talk about empty properties
but I'd like to actually know really
what are because I've I've got empty
properties on my patch which I've
involved Council officers in in the past
and I've suddenly learned that actually
it's hugely difficult to do anything
about it legally and then secondly
there's there's all sorts of financial
liabilities from the council if we get
involved too much because suddenly we
start taking on the and I think again I
would welcome a as part of that brief a
brief on what is actually the actual
situation legally procedurally what what
can we do what can't we do and then what
have we done so far or not um so that we
have a more informed
view um as to um why perhaps we haven't
made the Headway in this area that many
of us may feel we haven't made um but I
don't know but I you know somebody give
me some statistic to say how many we
have actually managed to um bring back
into service Etc so that's my suggestion
that we add the timing of which would be
subject to discussing would be a
affordable housing yeah and empty
properties they're B the
um um one one one is one is planning one
is environmental side but um um we would
probably take it
together happy I'm seeing that not okay
um we will look to add that anything
else that people um want
to see at the moment on the forward plan
bearing in mind that we've got a bit of
a l jam and we need it it needs to be um
filtered to the right a bit anyway um
cycle 7 is is reserved for budget so we
don't want to be putting anything in
there
um so we're starting to to look at
populating Cycles into next year um
anything else anybody's wanting to put
Mr chairman can I just ask a quick
question this
um the timing of the review of the QV
process has that been set in tablets of
stone or could that not
be uh moved to um the February me not
the February meeting the March meeting
so that it would be ready for start
starting in 4 to uh one of the next
financial year is or have we made a
commitment to renewing reviewing sorry
this in the timing of that I think I'm
just looking at chief executive timing
of that was driven partially by the
budget setting I think wasn't it in that
that was in place for the next budget
don't I think it was something you had a
discussion at an earlier meeting and you
just scheduled it on the forward plan
rather than it had to be done for any
specific reason it's ch I can can remind
you um because there was a new committee
yeah you wanted to go through two
quarters of the qbr and then have the
review so it's not set in stone it was
purely actually we've we've had two qbrs
now she now is it time to have a look at
it we are drafting a questionnaire to go
out but that hasn't been done yet so it
is not setting done yeah it's not set
it's not it's just a could I make a
proposal that we postpone that until
cycle 7 which
Cy
sorry
sorry got two c sens the one yeah um
cycle seven and a half the budget the
budget special shouldn't be a cycle or I
suspect or it should be 6A or something
um is that right yeah yeah so um
uh it be 19th of March onwards anyway
um yes if by by your suggestion uh
councelor Hudson it it is obvious that
the the qbr review is is movable and
when when I sit down with a t we just
look at the other things the high
likelihood that that one could it's not
it's not driven by St and it thank you
for sharing that it's a
it's a questionnaire we want to put out
to counselors and officers just to try
to find out and it doesn't have to be a
a particularly lengthy item either the
idea being if there's just any areas
where it can be fine-tune or tweak to
either make it easier from an input
point of view or easier from an
extraction point of view more useful um
to people um nothing more than that um
I just make one comment here um I guess
Sly one SLE would be fine I wouldn't
Enis s any further now we have a peer
review coming up and it'd be useful if
that if that process is done before we
go through that process because then we
know we've got we've got it fine tune
and also just one cycle would be
preferable than any later the night yeah
um so not the March one no the March one
will probably
um that' be fine um thank you for
that no but absolutely freise up a bit
of time no indeed um anything else at
this
point U go Jo got the draft EST strategy
there we had a task and finish group
looking at that maybe over a year ago so
what's the states of that is that they'
be ready for going out to consultation
or
um it was it's just on the work program
and an action in the economic business
plan they've got all the details from
the task and finish group um it's just
down to priorities as I understand it
and work
though there was hoping that it'll be
ready for there but I
yeah I just mention one
chair thank you um yeah we we've got a
meeting hopefully on the 29th of
November this month to have a a training
session with uh an officer from exitor
we've got a draft um that um been
provided from the ogga that we're
looking at and we've got some metrics
that we're hoping to pull together so
after that meeting of the 29th whether
it's December or February or March we
should be able to bring something to
this commit somebody be able to bring an
update to us at that stage yeah yes and
that could be fairly short I'd imagine
and it would be just a question of you
briefing us but um okay yes just we
don't want to lose sight on that but
good to hear
that good go back I mean presumbly
there'll be some end date when the draft
D strategy will be completed because
it's somewh out of date isn't it so I
mean really it doesn't go on and on
being put on the forward plan there must
be some idea of when it's going to
be in a form where it can go out
consultation we'll have a look at it I'm
got details with me
so um we'll pick up with the team I did
speak to them and that's what I just
said was was the response I had so but
we'll check again was on the on the EST
Strat yeah thank you just the word hope
is you I think expecting more than hope
in April because it the point was that
the questions be raised two years ago
and the strategy will now be 10 years as
of 2024 so I think a bit more than hope
perhaps okay I guess we got the same
officers working on the same plan so we
got an economic strategy that's coming
forward uh we've got a leveling that
partnership that we have to start to
bring forward with a strategic plan
which needs to be done and we've got all
the same op is doing all the same thing
so some things have to take priority
over others I'm afraid yeah yeah okay
um fine if we
can we just get another update get yeah
if we can have an update as to where
they're at where they're actually at
with it and that be kind uh council is
anything
else good right well first of all thank
you for your time and if that's the case
then I declare minute meeting Clos and
we are meeting